[Music]
so
okay the uh kazushi pattern of ikeomote
is the front inward
it is the young hand
of kokuho
okay the
this part
there's there's techniques within
technique okay the kihon wasa is a
ritual it's not a
fighting application okay
my
atemi
is
in here
so
i do have to he's pushing
i do have to ground it does have to go
into the center
but my hand so my
the rebounding energies coming through
me ground going back to his center back
to the center but their tummy
is going to in his face okay
so if he lets go
it goes right to his face okay
over here
it's not just going into its face
still getting his center
but this is wrong too
this path
he is tasked in the ritual
and not letting go of his grip
because he's my
energy that i'm working with the energy
that he provides
either in his prescribed
angle of attack but also and more
importantly just the energy of gravity
working on his mast okay
all that is what comes into me
into his center
but in an attempt
if i'm doing my job and he's doing his
job
i cannot hit him in the face
if
he
stops his job
in any number of ways
you will hit him in the face
okay
one way is
he feels it he let's go
you're gonna hit him
another way is
is he resists the energy well this
cannot stop oh
you're going to hit him
some ways you resist without realizing
it
is you try to slow noggin down
that's resistance
another way is
one side of your head of your body in
this case your head
is being slowed down by the other side
of your body
it's dragging you're gonna catch up boom
you're gonna hit
okay
if you have
your body as a unified hole
such that he goes right now my head went
do you see
but the energy is trapped in my shoulder
because my leg
is resisting my head lowering
so if i do the technique and i kick the
leg out
my whole body gets smooth
this is in essence what he's doing is
noggin
so my energy goes in
and he uses his whole body
to make it work
but he's doing it from a young side of
the mirror on the inside of the mirror i
let him move my whole body
but i have to keep my whole body
connected
if my body segments
here in the shoulder this side's dragged
to the autopsy turvy he's gonna hit me
so much so
that it's not about grip strength
i have the same ikey adhesion
and he can't beat me
it's not me running away from
it i disconnected
[Music]
nowhere is he near my head can you see
okay so we'll do
that
that part is here
you see
but we're going to do it
at a less intense level
you don't have fire to fall
okay
but your hand will go
close to his face
boys
see i don't get near his head
okay let's go
hey
you're not doing eko at this point
you're doing a strike in a throw
okay
so just like he went flying in the last
technique
he should go flying on this character oh
i'm doing this
[Music]
you got it it's not it's not easy
so my center
is attacking his center
you're not trying to find his arm
you see you're not out here
you're in here
watch how close i am
in
i can't hit him in the face
because he's connected
okay
all right
you pay attention you're not in the
vehicle yet
so
slower so you can see
and clearing the line from this angle of
attack here okay this is what's going to
send him into the front position see
that
but i'm not here and just
hitting him in the face what do i have
to have i have to have his center okay
so let's say he let's go and i'm going
to do that strike it's not this
it's the same boom in his body you see
where where i'm just going to touch it's
in his body boom
you understand
i'm not trying to smack him
i'm using a tummy
he let's go
and take his whole body boom
in his center
your your kid's going to let go
okay so you're not doing this
you can go let go and you have to have
your block
oh so he can't resist
to kind of resist push back doesn't
matter in his body whoa
you understand say yes it's pretty
obvious okay you're not here like this
it's it hits his whole center
okay let's go hit his whole center
okay try it
again okay i'm not going to do the
antenna because i don't want to knock
him out but i want you to understand uh
the the energy that you're using here
okay so i'll use it on his mask
it's not going to cause the top to turn
me a bit
you'll be able to see
that
just like i'm here i'm not pushing them
like this
you see i'm using my
ground
okay so let's move this arm out of the
way because i'm gonna touch you right
here our body is going here
using the energy of his mass okay
the gravitational pull
is what i end up grounding the
gravitational pull of his mass
is what i end up grounding and
projecting out
not out here
feel that energy right there that's what
goes into
and gets him to bounce off myself okay
so here you go let go
boom that is what you're hitting with
that okay try it again
okay so already you have some strategy
that you're learning so always take the
guy's battle
that's the strike always take their
balance
always attack the body primarily and the
arm is secondary the arm is secondarily
okay
you don't you don't you don't try to get
somebody centered with their arm
that's not correct you already have
their center and you continue to have
their center while you're touching the
arm is entirely different what does one
look like like this
you see
look look how he's already
going off balance already going off
balance you see
okay it's gonna do something
that's what it pays the arm opening
because otherwise i'd go flying
okay
so what sukkah is supposed to do well
luke is prescribed to give the initial
energy
and then they're now tasked with
reconciling
yong
with yin so they give the initial young
energy to establish the conflict he goes
in and then he goes
what i'm going to do is go around his
energy i'm going to go around the energy
of the atemi so here's his attempt
to stay here i get hit
i'm going to go around his energy my
whole body and look him on the other
side of his arm
here
around to the other side of his arm
not he does that to me
not he does it to me
i did it to him i took away his throw
going to the other side of his arm
i move my head out of the way
i don't let my foot pull on my head
because he'll hit me bow
and i go around his arm
this is how my center doesn't get moved
into the throat
[Music]
okay try that car
so i'm doing the uh
he counters it you see and it allows his
center to stay still and that's what
allows the skin space for the
if he tried to resist i'm going to come
out because he can't
and fingers are strong enough
if he
it tries to
elbow it's going to hit him
if he lets his foot break center so
remember center
is a equal relationship with the two
peripheries in this case the foot and
head so if he bends at the waist
then i'm going to hit him
[Music]
so he has to counter the atemi and
counter the kazushi so he establishes a
relationship between his head and his
feet that will make his head miss the
atemi he goes around the energy and
that's what takes his center out of the
kazushi and there's my edema where i
again repeat this strategy
attack the body
not the arm
you understand
so let's say he did not go around
but he kept
the center
lock it
i won't get the attempt but what would i
get
the kazushi
you understand
this is how you get rid of both
form that opens that opening
i am touching the arm but he countered
it
i ain't going back into the section
couches it hold back into
do not get the arm
get the body
you can't forget that part
[Music]
for example if you had multiple people
counters you go here you can still get
someone else
counselor in
okay i want to see that
and re-attack the body
so when you
do go to
control the limbs
it's never you pulling on the limbs
you're sticking to the limbs okay that's
from your nail
you can't pull people's arms they're
just going to pull against you and get
out
got it okay so
pay attention
the mistakes that i'm seeing are
starting way out here
you'll have no intention of hitting that
guy in the face let's rewind the film
and look at the mind
let's let him let go see if i'll hit him
watch where my
body is
do you think then he has to counter
because i'm not interested in his arm
i'm interested in his center he counters
and i am touching his arm but i'm not
pulling it i'm not grabbing it
i'm just stuck to it which is why i can
let go of it
and do the same kazushi
what i'm seeing instead
is you're over here
pulling on the arm
he is turning around me but it's because
of my edemi angle and i'm sticking with
his hand
i'm not pulling on him i'm attacking the
center i'm just touching this
and sticking to it
boom
sticking to
you it my hand is open
panda is open
you see that okay try it again
i tell you try kazushi he counters goes
around now that he's down now his center
is controlled
here's where i'm going to attack the arm
to attack the arm i need his elbow right
on my center line i don't want to be
like this you see how i brought his
elbow around my center line when i take
one more step
i'm now on the inside of his elbow and
here it is tap out
i'm not gonna float bach out
and get his arm
with this stuff
boom
down here right there i take one more
step around and you can see my hand is
on the inside attacking this way
so here's your break
you and the keyhole
will pass by that break
but you have to pass by it
you're going to do the technique
[Music]
it's right there
different
you understand that's not it
right here it is
[Music]
he feels the weight
right there it is i pass it
[Music]
hey
let's go okay so uh if you need a
dressage pony again okay so the dressage
pony is working on i push his line of
gravity out
and then there's no leg on the table
over here so he comes with me okay but
you saw when i didn't tell him to go
with me oh
you're pulling on him that's not aikido
okay
likewise
when i go here
full
you're gonna think
i'll bring it like this
i'll just bring it around
and then
will you go ahead and fall for me
but i had to tell him to do it
i i not
i'm not doing the break
but the teacher should be able to see
that you have the inward energy
you're not just going
up the circle like this
i'm on the outside
boom counters did put you can see it
promise right there okay
well i just going around that part there
it is right there and i'm going around
it
okay let me out
okay i'm not just getting out of the way
so the lazy uk
just lets gravity work on their shoulder
and they lay down okay
try it again